now we often hear about the American
dream but what about success stories
here in Britain my next guest knows what
it's like to work your way up from the
bottom age 13 a military coup forced his
family to leave Nigeria and start a new
life in the East End of London they had
little money but against the odds that
13 year old has gone on to become
Britain's first black police and crime
commissioner earlier this week I sat
down with Festus akumbosoye we discussed
his journey into the role the racism he
suffered along the way and one of the
top stories of the week trust in
policing
professoria thank you so much for coming
on Beth Rigby interviews now
you're a very interesting man with a
very interesting future you are the
country's fast uh black police and crime
commissioner what does that achievement
mean to you
for me it means that actually this is a
country where anything is possible
I remember some people saying to me with
a name like Festus and I came with
Sawyer when no one will vote for you and
they were wrong I end up winning the
highest share of votes of any police and
crime commissioner in that in that area
it just goes to show that anything is
possible Your Story begins with your
childhood growing up in Nigeria can you
explain how you and your family came to
settle in the UK when you were 13 years
old well Dad was a politician in Nigeria
and having won an election I um I know
there was a real in political
instability at the time a miniature
detector came into into power and all
the elections were overruled so dad came
to England and we came to join in my
twin sister and and I and my mom and
that was quite a culture shock for us I
mean we lived in a pretty affluent
environment we're very comfortable to
now live in a two bedroom flat four of
us with another family of four so eight
of us and a two-bedroom flat in Upton
Park
and your dad
became
an immigrant holding down three jobs
yeah to make ends meet did it hurt his
prime absolutely you know but the thing
that actually taught to me
was that so long as you're working hard
and you're willing to put in the effort
um you've got to do what you've got to
do to provide for your family despite
the difficulties and sometimes you've
got to start at the bottom and that's
okay I just want to talk a bit more
about your politics because you stood
for election as an MP in West Ham in
2015. why is it do you think that
ethnically diverse people in the UK that
64 of them in the according to the
recent poll polling shows that they vote
labor and 20 vote conservative I think
there's some generational
um aspect to this where people tend to
vote the way their parents voted so it's
no surprise to me that when first
generation migrants come to the UK
they sometimes see the labor party as
the party of the working people one
quasiquant time was chance a labor MP
called him superficially black because
he was a tory
what did that instant make you feel as a
black conservative that was
exceptionally
exceptionally
um disgusting
it was exceptionally in my view racist
and stereo stereotyping in the worst way
because he was suggesting that to be
black you have to be able to speak a
certain way to be black you cannot go to
Eaton or Oxford or the top schools in
the world because that's not what black
people do I thought was reprehensible
the Civil report which examined racial
disparities in the UK got into hot water
when it appeared to conclude that UK
Society wasn't institutionally racist
what was what was your take on that
I can hand on heart say personally
the color of my skin has never prevented
me from achieving anything I wanted to
achieve in this country that said there
is no question in my mind that there are
racist individuals out there I get the
abuse from some of these on social media
there is one that might be coming in in
the public domain in a couple of months
to come in terms of racial abuse and
that I've received
um
it was it was quite a serious one right
you know with threats to my family it
was quite a serious one okay quite a
serious one sorry I'm sorry I mean you
know Dan Abbott faces this you know
David Lammy faces did
um quasi as you just mentioned faces
Kami faces this you know Rishi now is
facing it you know it's it's
unfortunately there are some people in
Britain who do not like to see people
with this different skin color uh in
positions of influence and power Boris
Johnson has written the past I know it
was a long time ago but he did talk
about out picking the knees and
watermelon Smiles did that trouble you I
think he might have apologized for those
um if you were to ask him again if he
will use those same language in another
book I'm sure he probably wouldn't see
that but personally
I don't there's any space there's any
room for that kind of language it's not
something I would well well let's get
back to you let's stop talking about all
these other politicians
you are as I said the fast black police
and crime session you yourself have been
stopped and searched I think at least
six times yes is that correct yeah yeah
three times in London uh when I was
growing up here once in Hertfordshire
once in buckinghamshire and once in
bedfordshire I wanted to ask you like
has it happened to your sons do you
worry for your sons
thankfully hasn't happened to know my
children yet but the thing is this I
have used because I I train to be a
special Constable with benefits of
police before I became a police and
crime commissioner and I got to see for
myself firsthand how the powers are used
I saw this I got to see the necessity of
it and it's something that we need that
the police need to have in their Arsenal
in keeping our communities safe
but it's not it is a blunt tool so you
support it I support the appropriate use
of it right uh and the justifiable so
it's used inappropriately often
sometimes with that question of course
okay wasn't I wasn't I think 19 years
old yeah I was coming from basketball
practice in White Chapel and my goal
stopped and I asked the officer why did
you stop me and he said to me just to
make sure you know one of London's Most
Wanted
that was it
how'd you thought maybe were you angry
at the time I didn't really care because
I need a lot of my friends dealt with
that but the older I got knowing what I
know now I'm like well that's kind of
that was just wrong there was no need
for that I just would love to see
policing also understand how its
coercive Powers have an impact on people
um who are most affected by it I mean
someone called you a traitor when you
took this job was that
was it painful for you but did you
understand why can you understand no I
can understand why absolutely not I mean
you know I I I'm a conservative because
I want to be I know my history as a
black person I know the history of this
country I'm not in denial of it I
welcome and celebrate the good but you
know I of course I will have to accept
they're not very good as well uh but the
conservative party is not
um a um a monolithic group for someone
to give me grief just because I'm in one
political party and dating the color of
my skin should not fit into that
political part I think it's just oh was
it because because people feel that the
police is institutionally racist and
it's disproportionately targeting young
black men in stop and search Etc so
people are mistrustful well I mean I've
been call Trader for that as well you
know you know but you know my thing is
this
um I feel very passionate about Law and
Order
um but there are those who like Carrick
who really are total shame to the
uniform that they wear but I'm here
because I want to make policing better
for all of our communities in London
where you grew up black londoners make
up 13 of the capital's total population
yet account for 45 of London's knife
murder victims and 61 of knife murder
perpetrators and 53 of knife crime
perpetrators this is a very
controversial one because there are some
people who would say well stop picking
on black people whatever it is but the
evidence is what it is you can't the
numbers don't lie I think there are
um
issues
that need addressing as a community but
it won't be addressed by people finger
points oh well there you go because
you're black you're more likely to be
killed so I'm gonna stop you more for
any other any reason whether you like it
or not I think we need to try to find
the right balance here this is one of
the reasons why I choose at some cost to
me and and my family to be as public as
I am
and it's because I want those young men
uh to see that whether actually whether
they're black or white whatever the case
might be but you know you can come from
a council estate
and be where I am today yes you can be a
football player yes you can be a
musician or be a stormzy or you could be
a burner boy whatever it is you want to
be can be whatever you want to be you
know but the reality is this there is a
an underworld
that is driving a lot of this violence
and arguments which you don't really
talk about as well which does not have
the racial Dimensions or the racial
narrative which is the use of drugs
you know a lot of the stabbers a lot of
the violence are driven by the demand
for drugs in Britain which is
phenomenal
uh and you know I I would love to see
more police resources being used in
dealing with this demand side
that is also driving this violence in
our communities what do you think that
not enough resources put into this area
because it is young black boys who are
suffering rather than middle class white
boys that's that's a tricky one
um and I would no one to
um assume a motive
but I see that a lot of effort is going
around enforcement
on those who sell and who deal but a lot
less goes on dealing with the users a
huge amount of resource goes into
enforcement for those who are selling uh
but very very little goes into there's
opposed to the middle class which he's
taking cocaine absolutely yeah and and
whether to demand there will be a supply
okay so you think that that is unfair
I think it's something that needs to be
looked at I need to ask you about David
the David Carrick case this week I know
he was a met officer but the case surely
has ramifications for all forces he's
not One Bad Apple as he is part of a
culture how much do you think it
undermines the police when I was giving
evidence before the home Affairs select
committee I said that I am tired of
hearing this line of one bad apples we
need to stop talking about that quite
rightly damn right the public expect
there to be no bad apples
but in the real world policing because
of the nature of what it is will
unfortunately attract people who have
ulterior motives and if they can get
through that system they will be able to
manifest those things
how worried you that a man with his
record could join the police force
maintain it over many years despite all
the signs he was violent and
intimidating and he'd been vetted
several times but a solution can't be
just about vetting alone because clearly
as we can see from this carrier case
people who have been vetted still get
through despite evidence but we need to
also have a situation whereby people who
complain within policing or externally
are taken more seriously and this is
looked into so in bedfordshire now since
I became PCC about seven officers have
been dismissed so are you confident that
this couldn't happen in your police
force
I would be dishonest if I was to say
that could never happen because like I
said we've got seven officers who have
dismissed they are now I think about 27
live cases that they're still
investigating for bedfordshire alone but
not not all of them are like rapes or
yeah yeah there could be all kinds of
different issues misogyny racism you
name it 27 Life Cases
27 Life Cases
but what I choose to do as a police and
crime commissioner which many other
pieces are doing is that I'm holding my
chief Constable accountable every single
month for this he spends time on the
front line with the officers he gets to
pick up things and already we are seeing
the benefit of that finally
um do you think that having a prime
minister from an ethnic minority Rishi
sunac our first ethnic minority and
Hindu prime minister a massive
achievement
um do you think it makes it easier or
harder for the conservative party to win
an election under him I think ultimately
will be the economy that decides what
people think I have a fulfill in their
pockets in their bank account in terms
of his ethnicity and encouraging others
uh I think sometime in this country you
know Beth we
on the state
they're really really good thing that's
happening here you know when Barack
Obama became the first black president
everybody was upping up with everybody
loved it was a great thing but when we
have the first uh you know brown skin
you know prime minister ever in this
country uh was was the big deal you know
I think we talked down this country a
bit too much and some of our major
achievements I think we should celebrate
Britain a lot more than we do okay well
Festus thank you so much for giving me
your time today I've thoroughly enjoyed
it thank you pleasure